you talk about family a lot in your book
and um apparently your mom watches the
show
let me tell you mammers tells me that
she watches your show
basically every day i talk to her pretty
much every day on facetime and every day
she reminds me
how much she loves you how great you are
how cute you are how positive you are
she loves your show
it like uplifts her she gets her coffee
she starts calling people but she's like
a drew barrymore stan she loves you
yeah oh my gosh i'm so excited well
let's bring her
in welcome everybody denise repino
hi timmy hi i'm so honored that you
watched the show
i'm so glad love your show
love it it's so awesome you have so much
joy
it's just been the best thing ever since
pandemic definitely oh
i'm looking around because i that's just
that we all
appreciate that so much and that's what
we're trying to do here acknowledge
reality
but get into the good stuff
and you do we gotta have some completely
i find optimism without reality is sort
of like
not my bag anymore i think i used to be
into that
um but now it's like how do we
acknowledge the world
and yet find our own way in it together
so i would love to do a rapid fire
question with you denise about megan
because i just find these unorthodox
questions so much more revealing than
the traditional ones
and we're going to do it in under well a
minute-ish i'm a pisces and i have no
time management so
um we're going to do megan in a minute
[Music]
okay ready the first person megan calls
when she gets good news
sue okay what was megan likely to get in
trouble for at school
probably talking too much in class oh
that's fun
and not so bad after all yeah i was like
it's fine i'm just having a conversation
don't worry about it teacher
yeah i'm like if that's your biggest
problem that's not so bad okay
whose posters did megan have on her
walls as a kid
michael jordan uh mia hamm michelle
akers
i had superman debbie harry and kiss um
okay one chore megan always hated
well cleaning your bedroom but really
all chores all chores
she had bigger fish to fry um okay do
you remember the first movie megan watts
everything disney and then everything
jim carrey
[Music]
okay dumb and dumber is a masterpiece it
should be number one on the afi
top 100. um megan's favorite meal as a
kid
chicken and dumplings oh that just made
me so hungry
megan how do you feel your mom got those
right
yeah i think she pretty much nailed
everything
you were really paying attention when i
was a child
oh very much so yeah i
love mothers and daughters i feel like
that is my
emotional journey in this world a big
part of my destiny and it is just
i now have two daughters you know a lot
of my life was sort of being my own
mother working out things with my mom i
loved so much of the things she did and
then i had to learn
how to do things differently at the same
time and you know
the bond and the relationship and the
journey between mothers and daughters
is just it's what i know it's what i've
experienced
and it is all about the human condition
and the heart and i love your guys's
relationship it's been so fun to delve
into your life and your family and your
journey
and it's just been so joyous
and empowering and inspiring and i love
that you guys are so close
and the mamr's tattoo and just
everything i celebrate you both and i'm
so
i feel so lucky that you came on this
show thank you for being here today
[Music]
thank you for having us so wonderful and
thank you for everything
you put out into the world your strength
is very inspiring and people watch it
and then they live their own life
you know with that in mind so it's
extremely important and thank you so
much
megan and denise one life is available
right now